i
like data i'm a big data guy data tells
a story
right if i pull up data i can learn a
lot about anything
data if i'm running a business say i'm
uh selling uh alcohol okay
run my dates on what day i sell what the
most and then i'll say okay i see trend
december
such and such wow people drink a lot on
thanksgiving day and you know stats
showing that
thanksgiving eve is the the highest
drinking day
of the the year and by the way that's
actually a factual
statement and research i've seen right
so okay so while you're talking i go
online and i say
what are the most common zodiac signs to
believe in god
and what comes up is it says three
zodiac signs
who are most likely to become atheists
okay
capricorn virgo taurus okay
then i go and pull up to prepare for the
interview i'm like you know what i'm
curious
what zodiac sign have we had the most
presidents with used to be five
five i'm sure you know this now biden
made it six five scorpions are at the
top
then you got aquarius is that five which
is lincoln fdr
harrison mckinley then you got cancer
capricorn leo libra pisces tied at four
then he got gemini and sagittarius three
aries and virgo is two right and then
gemini's you got jfk bush senior and
trump all the same
interesting leo's you got obama clinton
sane
interesting so so i look at a lot of
data
and and you know i mean by the way
there's some crazy data that's been
pulled up i don't know like the data if
you've done
research on this yourself cancers are
the most dangerous according to fbi data
shows that cancers are the most
frequently arrested of all signs and
their crimes are often most
more serious than others cancers right
you got tesla elon musk tom cruise robin
williams george michael
leos are most likely to hit the gym the
most twice as much as everybody else
leos are also the worst drivers they get
40 more speeding tickets than libras
except
this libra i guarantee you i got all
leo's beating and speeding tickets
that's a promise right there
right so i go into this you know the top
athletes are frequently
aquarians you know michael jordan you
know 21
of top best athletes in all sports
aquarians number uh
second place is cancer 12 so again i can
go on serial killers
or two signs pisces and gemini i pull up
all this data
and it tells you something so how much
of it
is like is there that much of if you are
a sign and how you are
that's gonna dictate how you're going to
be i mean
you know data can tell us a story what
are your thoughts about the data that
links to different signs well the data
doesn't
tell anything about dictation
it tells about how people either were
able
to use their sun sign energy
for positive things or negative things
and the most serious negative things
usually come
out of experiences in the first
28 years of a person's life usually in
the first 14
and the reason for that is that in those
first 14 years of
life half of them is the development of
the ego
and the other half is the ego trying to
figure out how to feel about that
so there there you are you know um
in those in those uh in in your in your
situation
you you have uh the reason you do this
is you have uh something in virgo
called saturn and it's in the house of
what is valuable and what to you
is valuable is your analysis and your
breakdown
and you give some kind of structure as
to
what people are doing what kind of work
are they doing how are they
you're interested in all kinds of data
that's what virgo
is like very critically critical
analysis
i mean you go up and down on data alone
but the idea also with astrology is you
have to be careful with that because
take for instance the gemini's right
that was kennedy and
then there's you know trump trump
whatever
he can't remember isn't he your favorite
president i thought he's your favorite
place
a picture in the background of his uh he
was my favorite favorite
president uh
kennedy uh as a gemini
uh was not
like trump gemini
function is to confront conflict and
resolve it
but a gemini like trump will take
uh conflict and use it to separate and
split people up
to keep himself in power that's how
that's how he works that's how he gains
power he just turns people against each
other and that's
everything he ever did whereas kennedy
did the opposite he did the gemini thing
of bringing people together
and overcoming conflict and trying to
connect and communicate and understand
you know
first words out of his mouth
inauguration friends and foes alike
you know talking to everybody we're
going to connect and we're going to be
real and you can count on us
now you asked a little earlier all these
years that i've been here and you've
only been here for 20
i saw i've seen this country decline
in very very slow serious way
for just the word organic food
what a mind-blowing thing that is i grew
up and there was nothing but organic
food
there's all there was no chemical there
was no big ad
and we had a lot of local farmers
and they didn't use pesticide because
they didn't exist
so they used the farmers almanacs they
used all kinds of things
but they did it organically and so forth
little by little
uh through all kinds of ways of
you know the agriculture department
united states the
the the government itself and the school
system
discovering that by the time he got to
world war ii
didn't have enough healthy kids to make
soldiers out of so there was this
school lunch program that was put
together and
that made it necessary for uh have
enough surplus to be able to give it
to them so you end up with a lot of
energy going into putting chemicals
into the ground as a way of growing more
food and on and on it goes until now
uh you have to pay extra to not have
food
with chemicals in it so that's only one
example of a political thing
i mean the political parties uh uh
in the formation of the country there
were never there weren't any political
parties when they formed this country in
1776
it never dawned on them so that's why
the electoral college is just a mess
because
they were thinking of all the states
being
bound together loosely by an agreement
to be part of the united states
and so they could have this vote and
they could do that but it was all about
slavery in the united states at the time
because
slaves uh the slave states didn't have
enough population
voting population to be able to uh
win an election they were all in the
bigger cities and so forth
well the solution to that was the
electoral college where
they said okay you guys are going to get
so many votes
and we're going to increase your
population by taking every
slave you have and counting it as
three-fifths of a person
now that that is that is where it all
starts and comes from
and racism uh you know the country the
united states for instance is a cancer
right
now cancer is all about race but it
means
human race it means human race because
it's an astrological
thing of god if you will and human
beings have turned it into racism
because uh the what you said about
cancers
perfectly fits the united states our
behavior in this world
you know we're we have this bring me
your poor your ground downtrodden and so
forth
and then you have a president like this
who does that so
cancer can be very viciously awful
mean and terrible and it can be also
very kind wonderful and nurturing
and it all depends upon what happens to
that
in the growing up stages so a country
has an ego just
person makes sense you know some of the
best leaders of my company are cancers
like i mean and i'm not talking about
one or two a number of them are cancers
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye